dans l'actualité ce soir la course
contre la montre dans l'essonne on est
toujours sans nouvelles d'une femme
enlevée lors de son jogging
elle avait pu appeler les gendarmes
alors qu'elle était enfermée dans le
coffre d'une voiture un homme déjà
condamné pour viol est en garde à vue
138 personnes arrêtées 122 personnes
libérées la quasi totalité des migrants
placés en rétention à calais il ya huit
jours ont été relâchés est ce un coup
d'épée dans l'eau nous ferons en direct
au ministère de l'immigration
nicolas sarkozy lance son plan daide à
la jeunesse le rsa le revenu de
solidarité active sera étendue aux 18 25
ans mais sous conditions la décision
avait été critiquée au sein même de la
majorité
la décision surprise de bnp paribas le
groupe décide de rembourser l'aide
publique accordée au plus fort de la
crise que sont devenus ces fameux
milliards versés aux banques l'état at
il fait une bonne affaire éléments de
réponse dans un instant la sphère roman
polanski vire la fronde politique de
nombreux élus prennent le contre-pied
des soutiens apportés au réalisateur
dans le même temps woody allen et martin
scorsese demande sa libération
enfin des bains de soleil en automne
nous évoquerons l'étonnante douceur des
températures qui persiste on verra qu'il
ya une explication du côté des océans
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous d'abord donc
cet enlèvement qui mobilise depuis hier
soir 200 gendarmes dans l'essonne celui
d'une femme de 49 ans de 42 ans pardon
sortie faire son jogging dans la forêt
de fontainebleau
elle a elle-même puis donné l' alerte
mais sans pouvoir dire où elle était
précisément les enquêteurs se disent ce
soir très inquiet pierre monnier fanny
stenneler christophe kenck marie
christine hodeau reste introuvable
ces dernières 36 heures son portrait a
été diffusé deux cents gendarmes et
pompiers ont ratissé les forêts où elle
faisait son jogging mariage mais rien
pas une trace depuis son dernier coup de
téléphone un appel au secours qu'elle a
passés aux gendarmes
c'était hier à 9 heures 10 du matin
elle nous indique d'une voix oppressée
mais très calme qu'elle a été agressée
alors qu'elle faisait son footing par un
homme armé d'un couteau qui l'a forcé à
entrer dans le coffre de son véhicule
les changes dure 2 minutes 17 puis la
conversation est coupée marie christine
hodeau a tout juste le temps d'indiquer
l'immatriculation de la voiture de son
ravisseur
une peugeot 106 de couleur grise elle
conduit les enquêteurs à 30 km de là
dans cette maison il interpelle
l'utilisateur habituel de la voiture et
perquisitionnent son domicile l'homme a
déjà été condamné pour viol une fois sa
peine sa peine purgée il est revenu sur
le sur le village ans c'est-à-dire aux
côtés de la famille de la petite fille
qui l'avait violée cette famille est
toujours sur le village effectivement il
savait susciter une certaine inquiétude
et une inquiétude qui pouvait être
légitime
les battues vont être suspendues à la
tombée de la nuit la zone de recherche
couvre des villages et des forêts sur
plus de 30 kilomètres de long et 10 de
large
bonsoir pierre monnier vous êtes en
direct sur place que sait-on de cet
homme exactement qui est en garde à vue
et s'agit-il d'une piste considérée
comme sérieuse
écoutez aux yeux des enquêteurs il fait
en tout cas figure de principal suspect
il s'agit d'un homme de 47 ans marié
père de famille employé comme gardien
d'une résidence secondaire à quelques
kilomètres d'ici
il a déjà été condamné en 2002 à 11 ans
de prison pour viol enlèvement et
séquestration sur une adolescente de 13
ans il a été libéré l'année dernière
mais reste inscrit au fichier des
délinquants sexuels ce soir sa garde à
vue a été prolongée
mais il nie toute participation à
l'enlèvement il faudra donc attendre
éventuellement des éléments matériels
notamment l' expertise de la voiture
qu'il utilisait les résultats devraient
être connus demain dans la journée
pierre monnet gier à milly-la-forêt
merci pierre on vous retrouve dans le
courant de ce journal en cas de nouveaux
développements bien sûr deuxième titre
de la qualité ce bilan huit jours après
l'opération contre le campement de
calais je vous le disais la
quasi-totalité des étrangers en
situation irrégulière
r placés en rétention ont été libérés
122 sur 138 exactement selon la cimade
décisions de tribunaux administratifs
suite semble-t-il à des problèmes de
droits ou en raison de l'âge des
migrants dont beaucoup seraient des
mineurs sophie rhodia nitry voir ce soir
ils sont presque tous libres
une semaine après la destruction de la
jungle beaucoup des afghans évacués sont
de retour à calais depuis que la jungle
est détruite un jour je dors ici un jour
dans la rue un jour dans un pas il y a
une semaine jour pour jour la jungle le
plus grand compte man sauvage de
migrants d'europe étaient démantelés
devant les caméras une opération
d'envergure en moins d'une heure 400
policiers arrêtent 276 migrants dont 125
se disent mineurs
sur les 151 majeurs interpellés 129 ont
été placés le jour même en centre de
rétention dans toute la france une
semaine après 89 d'entre eux ont déjà
été libérés et même plus selon les
associations
ces afghans étaient retenus à toulouse
ils ont été relâchés hier pour vice de
procédure
tholot ils nous ont juste emmener de
calais je ne sais pas pourquoi et nous
ont amenés ici si loin ce soir 34
migrants sont toujours en centre de
rétention ils sont susceptibles d'être
reconduits dans leur pays
ce matin encore un nouveau site a été
démantelé à calais pour le ministre de
l'immigration
le but affiché n'est pas d'interpeller
des migrants mais bien de mettre un coup
d'arrêt aux trafics d'êtres humains
alors cette opération est elle un coup
d'épée dans l'eau bonsoir franck
génaudeau vous êtes en direct du
ministère de l'immigration comment
réagit-on à ce bilan est bien cotée nous
étions tout à l'heure en compagnie du
ministre eric besson il s'est montré
tout à fait serein nous savions que
c'était un travail de longue haleine at
il affirmé alors nous les avons posé la
question de façon très directe est ce
qu'une semaine après le démantèlement de
la jungle
on est de retour à la case départ pas du
tout at il affirmé l'objectif était de
casser l'outil de travail des passeurs
et en cela selon lui l'opération est un
succès il y en aura d'ailleurs deux
autres dans les 48 heures à venir
je vous propose d'écouter eric besson
ministre de l'immigration
je n'ai jamais dit que tout s'achever
avec le démantèlement de la jungle j'ai
au contraire dit que c'était un travail
de longue haleine mais nous ne luttons
pas contre les migrants même s'ils
doivent savoir que en france il faut
venir en situation régulière
nous menons une lutte acharnée contre
les passeurs qui exploitent la misère
humaine
propos recueillis donc par franck gêne
au zoo à paris merci franck l'actualité
économique elle est très riche ce soir
on commence avec la flambée des impôts
locaux taxe d'habitation et taxe
foncière
vous l'avez peut être constaté en
recevoir votre courrier regarder ces
chiffres pour les communes
l'augmentation moyenne pour les 40 plus
grandes villes et de 5,1 pour cent pour
les départements allaient de 6,2 pour
cent
explication valérie le rouge nathalie
jour dans ce courrier la ne fait jamais
plaisir mais pour ce contribuable niçois
la taxe foncière est particulièrement
salée cette année 2374 euros en 2008
2674 d'euros en 2009 soit une hausse de
17% du côté de la mairie on justifie
cette envolée fiscale par le déficit
laissé par l'équipe précédente pourtant
elle aussi ump on était à terme assez
rapproché avec un risque d' mis sous
tutelle parce que simplement la
situation ne permettait pas les niveaux
d'investissement qui sont nécessaires
mais quelles que soient les querelles
locales
aucune ville ou presque n'échappe à la
flambée d'impôts locaux parmi les plus
fortes hausses de taxes foncières
d'abord argenteuil et grenoble + 12 %
mais ce 11 et demie nantes + 14 % mais
nantes est aussi la seule grande ville
où la taxe d'habitation cette fois est
en baisse -5%
elle augmente partout ailleurs car la
crise est passée par là et ce que les
communes et départements n'ont pas perçu
sur les ventes immobilières par exemple
doit être compensée autre raison les
élections municipales de 2008
la fin de mandat de des municipales a
sonné un petit coup de frein sur la
fiscalité
tout simplement pour apparaître aux
élections comme le plus modéré possible
il faut rattraper deuxième facteur
l'après élection il ya des projets faut
les financer
à paris la taxe foncière grimpe de 28%
c'est le record jusque là les
propriétaires n'en payer que la part
communale est rien au département une
exception aujourd'hui révolue
département de paris était le seul en
france à financer sa politique sociale
sans rien demander aux propriétaires et
en faisant peser la totalité de la
dépense sur les locataires nous sommes
alignés sur les autres départements
français seule consolation pour les
contribuables parisiens leurs impôts
locaux même en hausse
restent les plus bas de france un plan
pour les jeunes nicolas sarkozy l'a
dévoilé tout à l'heure à avignon on l'a
souvent dit c'est parmi les moins de 25
ans que le taux de chômage est le plus
fort
la crise n'a rien arrangé principal
dispositif annoncé aujourd'hui le rsa le
revenu de solidarité active sera étendue
aux 18 25 ans mais avec des conditions
car la mesure avait été critiquée au
sein même de la majorité
alix bouilhaguet guillaume michel
ce matin nicolas sarkozy espérait
trouver une oreille attentive dans cet
iut d'avignon pour séduire la jeune est
son atout maître
le revenu de solidarité active ou pas et
rémy jaune jamais parce que ça c'est la
condamnation l'assistanat
l'extension du rsa toucherait donc les
jeunes actifs de moins de 25 ans seuls
160 mille personnes sont concernées car
il ya une condition avoir travaillé deux
ans au cours des trois dernières années
nicolas sarkozy a opté pour cette mesure
en dépit de sa propre majorité
dis à mes propres amis politiques
je ne crains pas le débat tu es la
majorité doit être une majorité ouverte
sur la justice sur la justice et pas sur
l'idéologie
à droite c'est le soulagement pour ceux
qui redoutaient de voir le rsa
généralisé sans conditions aux moins de
25 ans on n'est pas de sortie de du
système scolaire celle de formation
immédiatement de recettes d'assistance
parce que ça c'était de mon point de vue
une erreur et l'erreur est évitée mais
des inquiétudes demeurent
le rsa est une bonne initiative pour
faire reprendre le travail
maintenant est-ce que ça doit durer la
vie des rats on le pose la question si
le rsa pour les jeunes ne semble pas
être une nouvelle pierre de discorde
entre nicolas sarkozy et sa majorité
de toute évidence la vigilance reste de
mise et puis ce plan contient d'autres
mesures et notamment le regroupement de
tous les organismes concernés dans un
grand service public de l'orientation la
création pour les 16 18 ans d'un droit à
la formation ou à l'emploi qui vise les
100 mille jeunes qui sortent sans
diplôme chaque année de l'école ou
encore l'allongement des bourses
étudiantes
à dix mois au lieu de 9 lorsque l'année
universitaire l'exigent
coût total de ce plan 500 millions
d'euros autre information économique
importante de cette journée c'est une
surprise bnp paribas a décidé de
devancer l'appel en remboursant plus tôt
que prévu l'aide de l'état accordée en
plein coeur de la crise financière soit
près de 5 milliards d'euros
annonce faite par baudouin prot le
directeur général alors on a souvent la
mémoire courte mais il y a un
cette aide de l'état aux banques avait
provoqué un tollé on avait parlé de
cadeau à la finance où en est-on
aujourd'hui
pour le savoir agnès molinier nous a
rejoint bonsoir agnès combien avait-on
versées et avec quel bilan
au total david c'était 21 milliards 300
millions d'euros
entrons dans le détail 7 milliards pour
les caisses d'epargne banque populaire
qui ont fusionné 5,1 milliards d'euros
on vient de le voir pour bnp paribas 3
et 3,4 milliards pour respectivement le
crédit agricole et la société générale
un peu plus d'un milliard pour le crédit
mutuel et la france avaient également
participé au sauvetage de la banque
européenne dexia
alors pourquoi ce remboursement si
rapide de bnp paribas
elle est même la première banque
européenne a remboursé l'argent derrière
les banques américaines qui l'ont déjà
fait
c'est parce que les activités bancaires
sont reparties de plus belles surtout
financières et bnp paribas dégage des
profits
vous le voyez 3 milliards 200 millions
rien dans les six premiers mois de 2009
alors finalement ce versement d'argent
est il une bonne ou une mauvaise affaire
pour l'état
d'abord ce n'était pas de l'argent donné
par l'état c'était de l'argent prêté on
l'a dit à des taux d'intérêt de 8 % à
peu près et c'est cela qui va rapporter
de l'argent à l'état bercy estime ses
gains à 1 milliard 400 millions d'ici la
fin de l'année rien pour l'opération
d'aujourd'hui ses 225 millions mais ce
remboursement rapide est aussi une bonne
affaire pour les banques puisque elle
elle se dégage de la tutelle de l'état
et elle l'espère aussi de la pression
politique
merci agnès et c'est une bonne opération
aussi pour la bnp car le cours de
l'action a doublé entre temps et
puisqu'on évoque la mondialisation nous
partons en inde où vous allez le voir
une tribu de 8000 indigènes qui luttent
pour sauver son territoire réussi à
trouver des appuis dans le monde entier
dans cette région l'une des plus isolées
du pays une multinationale est en train
d'ouvrir une mine de bauxite
c'est un mode de vie ancestral qui est
menacée envoyés spéciaux arnauld miguet
dominique marault tél
depuis des temps immémoriaux quelque
part à l'est de l'inde dans ses collines
sacrées de l'orissa vite une tribu les
dons clients une tribu animiste
habitants originels de l'ain
et c'est à pied que des femmes vont
chercher l'eau à la source
tous les matins dans ce jardin d'éden
coupés du reste du monde pour les
dongria chaque colline est un dieu alors
la nature on la respecte autant qu'on la
vénère mois pour rien au monde je vivrai
ailleurs cette forêt m'apporte tout ce
dont j'ai besoin
nourriture est bonne heure mais
aujourd'hui leur mode de vie leurs
traditions sont menacés car ces collines
sont très convoités elle regorge de
bauxite indispensable à la fabrication
d'aluminium les multinationales lorgne
depuis longtemps sur cette terre pour
alimenter l'industrie automobile ou
aéronautique s'étend tard société basée
à londres cotées en bourse
soutenu par le crédit agricole et des
fonds de pension américain à remporter
cet énorme marché
ici impossible d'entrer si les travaux
miniers n'ont pas encore officiellement
commencé au pied de l'énorme raffineries
les ong et les locaux se mobilisent et
voilà à quoi pourrait ressembler leur
avenir nous il en jette en prison si
l'on coupe un seul arbre mais pour
vedanta il n'y a pas de loi ils peuvent
raser tout cette montagne en toute
impunité au village n'est donc rien on
est loin de ces enjeux économiques
ici on vit depuis toujours de la
cueillette et de la chasse est pas
question de toucher à leurs montagnes et
les montagnes mam glisser notre dieu
notre mère tout ce qu'on mange tout ce
que je fais et grâce à niang guéri alors
on se prépare à déterrer la hache de
guerre est affûté les couteaux les 7900
dongria qui vivent ici dans la forêt ne
se laisseront pas faire
s'ils continuent on est prêt à en
découdre
on est même prêt à leur couper la tête
on leur a proposé de les reloger de
travailler à la mine mais pour l'instant
irréductibles ils ne veulent rien
entendre
la société minière vedanta n'a pas
souhaité répondre à nos questions la
tribu dongria elle a épuisé tous les
recours légaux et pourrait être chassée
de son territoire d'ici 2 mais plusieurs
associations internationales se sont
émus de cette situation
les suite de la vague de suicides à
france télécom pour la première fois le
parti socialiste et les députés
communistes réclament la démission du
pdg didier lombard
hier ce dernier a annoncé vouloir mettre
fin à la mobilité systématique des
cadres tous les trois ans mais la
contestation grandit spontanément
aujourd'hui plusieurs centaines de
personnes ont arrêté le travail pour
manifester à lyon denis sébastien thiéry
simonet pour un vent de colère une onde
de choc dans plusieurs villes de france
aujourd'hui comme ici à lyon
des centaines de salariés de france
télécom ont cessé le travail pour crier
leur indignation
les gens qui nous dirigent ne sont pas
des êtres humains
lombard n'est pas un être humain et ne
comprendra que rapport de force
la directrice régionale hué par ses
salariés comme pour le pdg de
l'entreprise la veille annecy après
plusieurs heures de discussions
houleuses
didier lombard s'est engagé hier soir à
diminuer la pression qui pèse sur ses
employés la pression correspond à ce qui
est nécessaire ce qui est induit par
l'état de la concurrence de la
régulation etc
mais il ya moyen de faire baisser cette
pression en étant plus humain dans
l'application des choses
deux mesures à effet immédiat la
suspension des objectifs commerciaux
imposer au salarié d'annecy et la
suppression de la mobilité des cadres
jusque-là obligatoire tous les trois ans
mais pour les syndicats cela ne suffit
pas alors là c'est pour tempérer on va
baisser la pression ici mais sur
l'ensemble des plateaux rien ne va
changer ce soir l'émotion reste très
forte dans toute l'entreprise france
télécom au lendemain du suicide de leur
collègue
les syndicats ont annoncé leur intention
de porter plainte pour mise en danger de
la vie d'autrui
en bref un accident mortel de tramway
aujourd'hui à bordeaux une femme de 70
ans qui promenait son chien a été
heurtée par une rame
elle n'a pas survécu quelques heures
plus tôt de l'autre côté de la ville
près du quartier mériadeck
un autre accident s'est produit cette
fois c'est un cycliste de 17 ans qui a
été renversé
ils avaient brûlé 1
le rouge ses jours ne sont pas en danger
le football en deuil après une mort
révoltante le supporteur de toulouse
brice taton violemment agressé il y a
deux semaines à belgrade en marge d'un
match n'a pas survécu à ses blessures
sur place yassine benzia met olivier
combe
brice taton 28 ans est mort sur son lit
d'hôpital après deux semaines d'agonie
colère et incompréhension chez les
supporteurs toulousains qui viennent de
perdre l'un des leurs
c'est très très très malheureux aller
voir un match de foot se faire tuer à
l'automne et ses terribles faut punir
ceux qui ont les pieds le 17 septembre
dernier brice taton et à belgrade pour
un match entre toulouse et le club du
partisan il est attablé dans cette
brasserie avec d'autres supporteurs
quand des hooligans serbes les attaques
par surprise
brice taton ne parvient pas à s'échapper
selon des témoins les hooligans se
déchaîne contre lui à coups de barres de
fer avant de le jeter par dessus un
muret de plusieurs mètres d'une violence
inouïe
cette affaire est pris très au sérieux
par les autorités serbes dix suspects
ont été arrêtés il risque entre 30 et 40
ans de prison
ce n'est pas seulement un meurtre c'est
aussi une atteinte grave à l'image du
peuple serbe
c'est pourquoi les auteurs seront
sévèrement punis quand brice taton était
entre la vie et la mort
les supporteurs toulousains affichaient
leurs espoirs aujourd'hui ils rejoignent
la triste liste des clubs en deuil
la violence dans le football a fait au
moins sept morts en europe
ces dix dernières années les derniers
développements de la sphère romane
polanski en suisse ses avocats ont
officiellement demandé sa remise en
liberté et déposé un recours contre le
mandat d'arrêt la décision devrait être
rendue que dans les prochaines semaines
image aussi de son épouse la comédienne
et chanteuse emmanuelle seigner qui lui
avait rendu visite hier elle est
retournée
ensuite en france à paris la france où
la sphère prend un tour politique de
nombreux élus prennent le contre-pied
des soutiens apportés au réalisateur
thierry curtet mourad boureïma c'est un
peu sinistre cette histoire franchement
bernard kouchner frédéric mitterrand les
deux ministres 7 et ému de l'arrestation
de roman polanski le ministre de la
culture a les mêmes un peu plus loin
dimanche soir
le président de la république suit le
dossier très attentivement j'ai eu
l'occasion d'en parler avec lui ce matin
et je pense qu'il est au même diapason
d'émotion que moi mais la première
réaction à contre-pied venue de daniel
cohn bendit hier au soir
il condamnait la précipitation de
frédéric mitterrand j'attends de voir
les dossiers
moi je trouve c'est tout à droite on ne
fait pas beaucoup plus preuve de
solidarité avec les deux ministres du
gouvernement dit que les ministres à mon
avis on était un peu vite pour faire des
réactions je crois que la suisse on ne
peut pas avoir de doutes sur
l'indépendance de la justice suisse
qu'il s'agisse d'un simple citoyen ou de
quelqu'un qui est mondialement connu à
mon avis le sujet est le même et on ne
peut pas faire deux poids deux mesures
marie george buffet elle non plus ne
pardonne pas même si elle s'interroge je
n'excuse pas le fait que cet homme même
s'il est un grand cinéaste
et oui cette erreur et puis on se dit
maintenant si bien des années en arrière
est-ce que c'est maintenant qu'il faut
relancer la machine judiciaire et c'est
un revirement de la classe politique qui
fait écho aux indignations des
associations de protection de l'enfance
est à noter que dans le même temps aux
états unis plusieurs réalisateurs tels
woody allen ou martin scorsese ont signé
une pétition pour demander la libération
de roman polanski
un mot du procès clearstream dominique
de villepin sera entendu demain sur le
fond mais pour la première fois depuis
le début de l'audience il s'est exprimé
sur les faits dès aujourd'hui je n'ai
jamais eu connaissance de ces listings
at il indiqué et je ne les ai jamais eus
entre les mains
l'ancien ministre vous le savez est
soupçonné d'avoir laissé faire la
manipulation en 2004 voire d'en avoir
été l'instigateur si l'on en croit les
conclusions des juges d'instruction
images signées zidène berkous
l'actualité à l'étranger avec d'abord le
lourd tribut payé par les civils dans la
guerre en afghanistan au moins 30
personnes en majorité des femmes et
les enfants ont été tués dans leur car
qui a explosé sur une mine dans la
province de kandahar
la réprobation internationale se fait
entendre après ce qu'il faut bien
appeler un massacre ponctuée d'actes de
barbarie en guinée on l'évoqué tiers la
junte a tiré dans la foule tuant au
moins 150 personnes nous avons reçu
aujourd'hui les premières images de ces
manifestations et de la répression
commentaires dorothée olliéric
venu pour manifester pacifiquement ils
sont brutalement chassée par l'armée les
militaires tirent sur la foule à balles
réelles
souvent à bout portant il y aura 157
morts et plus de 1200 personnes d un
carnage à massacre selon les opposants
et les témoins c'est un vrai désastre
affirme cette femme souche qu'ils ont
tué des gens
on a vu des femmes se faire violer et
des hommes qui le remettait des armes
entre les jambes
les manifestants étaient venus au stade
de conakry ce lundi matin pour protester
contre une candidature aux prochaines
élections présidentielles du capitaine
moussa dadis camara le chef de la junte
a pris le pouvoir en décembre dernier
mais aujourd'hui dans cette ancienne
colonie française
les guinéens demande son départ au
lendemain de cette fusillade la france a
suspendu sa coopération militaire avec
la guinée et a donné des consignes de
prudence aux 2500 ressortissants
français
retour en france avec pour la première
fois à paris un congrès sur un sujet
sensible comment devenir parents
quand on a été victime d'inceste de
nombreuses recherches ont été réalisées
sur cette question les témoignages sont
rares deux femmes directement concernés
ont accepté de raconter leurs
difficultés à être mère c'est le dossier
de cette édition il est signé florence
bouclier à virginie travers et abdel
zoud était hors de question de laisser
qui que ce soit touché mais bébé à la
maternité
je préférais ne pas m'approcher de lui
je pensais que je ne serais pas capable
d'être une bonne mère
j'avais peur d'eux
la nuit mais puisque je savais qu'on
m'avait abîmée sandrine à perth et marie
maubert ont toutes deux été victimes
d'inceste
comment être une mère quand on n'a pas
eu d'enfance maman d'un petit paul cette
femme a longtemps mis mais le bonheur 6
et c'est vraiment une pose pour la photo
c'est que là vous forcez en fait être
proche de lui et physiquement comme ça
oui car marie maubert ne parvient pas à
toucher son enfant et elle ne sait même
pas pourquoi
jusqu'à ce que des souvenirs viennent la
torture est petite elle a été violée au
sein de sa famille ceux qui avaient le
plus de pouvoir dans cette famille
élargie qui m'ont agressé un homme
sortir du déni bouleverse profondément
marie maubert mais ne la rend pas plus
affectueuses elle en souffre son fils
aussi terriblement il était très
demandeur de câlins il était très
demandeur de câlins donc évidemment
lorsqu'il venait sur mes genoux je ne
rejetait pas je le prenais mais c'est
pour moi c'est c'est pas quelque chose
d'agréable
c'est vraiment difficile elle non plus
n'a pas supporté les premiers contacts
avec son bébé ni que la sage femme va
opposer le nouveau né nu contre elle
aura pour le poids peau en fait ces
cantons
quand on demande à la mère une
d'enlever le
ou en fait d'avoir la peau nue et de
mettre son bébé pony contre sa collègue
pour moi ça c'est pareil c'était quelque
chose est pas envisageable parce que
dans mon esprit mais dans mon vécu
c'était un c'est sur son expérience
traumatisante
la jeune femme l'a mis au service de
cette école de sages-femmes l ai
rencontré un enseignant avec qui elle
doit assurer une formation sur l'a7
peuvent nous l'exprimer quand même
pendant la grossesse ou alors ils nous
tendent des perches et donc ça nous
savoir les saisir et ensuite de les
accompagner les victimes d'inceste ont
souvent des accouchements difficiles
il arrive même qu'elle craque devant une
équipe médicale méduses et parfois
surtout la femme ne l'a jamais verbalisé
à elle peut vraiment revivre par les
douleurs à la violence quand même
décontraction et l'accouchement au
revivre cet inceste et perdent
complètement pied au nom de son
accouchement
pire encore si l'auteur de l'inceste n'a
pas été dénoncé le séjour de la jeune
maman à l'hôpital peut être un calvaire
après la maternité à venir
la famille parfois l'agresseur parfois
l'agresseur va venir prendre le bébé
dans ses bras et que ça pour la mer
c'est insupportable aujourd'hui ces deux
mamans sont très proches de leurs
enfants mais elles n'ont pas vraiment
réussi à vivre en couple c'est compliqué
c'est compliqué parce que malgré tout on
a toujours un doute ou non là j'avais
confiance à 100% mais toujours maintient
là est-ce que
est-ce qu'elle n'a pas refroidi mire
dans un livre à paraître sandrine à
perth a recueilli de nombreux
témoignages de victimes d'inceste qui
racontent combien il aura été difficile
de devenir parents il est 20 heures et
24 minutes rester avec nous à suivre
faut-il parler de phénomène exceptionnel
presque partout un automne chaud éclair
s'est installée constat explication dans
un instant le frelon asiatique
s'installe en france il a été repérée
pour la première fois en ile-de-france
un prédateur pour les abeilles sa piqûre
peut aussi entraîner une hospitalisation
et puis quand le théâtre s'inspire de la
finance c'est l'une des pièces de la
rentrée le roman d'un trader avec lorànt
deutsch raconte la sphère kerviel à sa
manière bien sûr d'abord donc vous
l'avez constaté depuis quelques semaines
malgré quelques pluies
l'été joue les prolongations on se
baigne à saint malo en bronze à cannes
ça n'est sans doute pas une première
mais ce qui retient l'attention des
scientifiques
c'est surtout la température de l'eau
gilles marine est avec notre bureau à
montpellier sous le soleil de
palavas-les-flots cet après midi 28
degrés pour la quatrième fois depuis 50
ans l'été n'en finit plus la plupart des
habitants n'ont pas souvenir d'un mois
de septembre aussi radieux de journée du
mois de septembre des mois des moines
che non là c'est vraiment moi ou alors
on s'installe dans la chaleur avec un
seul mot d'ordre pourvu que ça dure on
n'a pas envie de rentrer dans l'hiver
malgré quelques matinée fraîche sinon
les après midi ensoleillé n'ont que du
bonheur déjà le mois d'août avait battu
des records de température un degré 3 de
plus en moyenne que l'an dernier
les ordinateurs de météo france et de
l'ifremer prévoit un univers doux l'une
des causes
l'augmentation de la température à la
surface des océans et notamment
l'atlantique entre 0,3 et 0,5 degrés
supplémentaires suffisants pour
réchauffer l'europe
tout petit chiffre quelques 03 05 degrés
peuvent entraîner des événements
climatiques qui sont beaucoup plus
importantes de plus grande ampleur et
donc par exemple les prévisions que nous
donne météo france c'est à dire un hiver
qui sera doux
un univers qui sera plus doux depuis 15
ans la température à la surface des
océans augmente légèrement et
régulièrement un effet du réchauffement
général mais les scientifiques restent
prudents la hausse constatée cette année
dans l'atlantique est due également à
des phénomènes climatiques saisonniers
encore très peu connus l'environnement
encore le fameux frelon asiatique semble
s'installer durablement en france il a
été repéré je vous le disais pour la
première fois dans la région parisienne
enquête laurence de chef david bazié
encore plus gros qu'un ballon de basket
ce nid de frelons asiatiques a été
repéré en région parisienne à 8 mètres
de hauteur dans un cerisier
ni les pompiers ni les entreprises
privées n'ont accepté d'intervenir au
regret de cette mère de famille le
premier apiculteur qui est venu
s'expliquer les partis à l'hôpital
donc je me suis dit que si mon bébé ou
ma fille faisait pitié quand je pourrai
s'il n'est pas déranger ce frelon
n'attaque pas l'homme
seuls les apiculteurs ont accepté de
retirer le nid car le frelon les
préoccupent les abeilles sont le repas
préféré
il faut beaucoup de nourriture pour
nourrir les oui parce que pour lui comme
ça il faut beaucoup de nourriture dogon
beaucoup d'insectes et ça détruit les
ruches et l'aele farce défendre
jusqu'ici leur ennemi c'était lui le
frelon européen
les abeilles savent le neutraliser comme
sur cette photo mais leur stratégie ne
fonctionne pas contre ces frelons
asiatiques qui attaquent temps masse
comme ici les abeilles vont devoir
s'adapter avec l'aide de l'homme
l'objectif de nos recherches c'est de
mettre au point des pièges sont d'aider
l'apiculteur et puis il était surtout
les russes se défendre soit fière
d'apporter une sorte de béquille ruche
quillan permettrait d'élaborer leur
propre défense et des millions de nos
francs qui venaient d'attaquer
depuis son arrivée en 2004 dans une
cargaison chinoise le frelon asiatique
prend ses aises en france et le climat
européen du convient si bien qu'il
pourrait même s'installer ailleurs en
europe dans toutes les zones en rouge
il est aujourd'hui impossible de s'en
débarrasser de plus il n'a pas encore de
prédateurs chez les oiseaux les
européens et les abeilles vont devoir
apprendre à vivre avec du théâtre
maintenant mais du théâtre ancré dans la
réalité la pièce s'intitule le roman
d'un trader elle est directement inspiré
de l'histoire de jérôme kerviel avec
lorànt deutsch dans le rôle principal
anis marie-hélène bono frédérick basile
du toit d'une grande banque française
un trader tombe il a fait perdre 25
milliards d'euros à sa banque
son fantôme vient hanter les vivants
lorànt deutsch 32 ans même âge presque
même rôle que jérôme kerviel accusé par
la société générale d'avoir causé près
de 5 milliards d'euros de pertes en un
week end
aujourd'hui c'est plus la peine d'être
un faux monnayeur pour fabriquer de
l'argent
il suffit simplement d'envoyer des vifs
électronique dans les circuits
d'échangés interbancaires et à moi j'en
apprends à écrire et si ça mon savon
quoi tu auras tu peux aller maintenant
et maintenant je je il faut imaginer ces
mecs qui jouent toute la nuit des nuits
entières devant leur écran devant
l'ordinateur et qui finissent par
tellement être déconnecté du réel qui
survivent à l'heure proprement enfin
qu'ils sont persuadés que mourir c'est
pas grave comme dans un jeu vidéo
ce monde virtuel cette intensité
dramatique
existe-t-il dans la réalité nous avons
réuni de vrais traders est l'auteur du
texte
vous avez eu cette idée de faire cette
pièce pourquoi kerviel c'est à dire que
c'est une icône
c'était devenez hamadan et nikon ont
donc c'est un héros quand même content
par en question alors trader acteurs
mais les émotions qu'on saisit très bien
l'intensité dramatique tout au long de
la pièce
évidemment la crise pratiquement de
nerfs qui atteint avec fini par
atteindre tous les tous les acteurs dans
la pièce on découvre que c'est le
directeur de la banque qui a jeté le
trader par la fenêtre
toute ressemblance avec la réalité
serait disons très exagérées avant de
refermer ce journal je vous en rappelle
l'un des principaux titres la course
contre la montre dans l'essonne on est
toujours sans nouvelles d'une femme
enlevée lors de son jogging
elle avait pu appeler les gendarmes
alors qu'elle était enfermée dans le
coffre d'une voiture mais sans pouvoir
se faire repérer un suspect déjà
condamné pour viol
et ce soir toujours en garde à vue fin
de cette édition merci de l'avoir suivi
tout de suite la météo laurent romejko
c'est toujours la douceur 20h35 vous
avez rendez vous avec une émission
spéciale se libérer de l'alcool
autour d'élise lucet avec les nombreux
invités hervé chabalier françois cluzet
notamment à demain
l'info en continu et aussi sur france 2
point fr